as part of GameSpot's next big game
coverage of evolve we're running a
little recruitment drive for all you
prospective hunters so you want to be a
medic good because every group of crazed
idiots that picks fights with huge
deadly monsters is gonna need someone to
help them deal with their imminent
deaths that's where you come in Lazarus
as one of the three different medics
that will be available in involved
you're uniquely qualified to stare death
in the face and not blink just don't try
to stare this thing in the face
Lazarus is a lurker a shadow a guardian
angel that should neither be seen nor
heard by the monster a silenced sniper
rifle insures the ladder and you'll use
that bad boy to punch holes in the
monsters armor so your trio of suicidal
companions can better whittle down the
beasts health covering your quarry with
bracketed weak points does confer a nice
sense of accomplishment but don't get it
twisted soldier there's a reason only
one of your abilities as an actual gun
you are here to patch up bar boys and
girls on the frontlines so snipe in your
spare time but when the battle gets
heated keep your eyes on your allies
when someone's health nears the halfway
mark that's when you should swoop in pop
off a quick healing burst and get clear
of combat you want to minimize the time
that you're in close proximity to your
teammates because the monsters number
one most favoritest thing is tightly
clustered groups of hunters that's
number two most favoritest thing is
isolating and killing the medic that's
you so if you sense a hulking land squid
is on your tail
pop that in visibility and take evasive
action invisibility is perhaps your
second most important power so five god
you better be frugal with it not just
pop it off to shake some low on the food
chain beasty that decided to get
friendly you use it to evade direct
monster aggression and to save your
teammates from the cold embrace of the
Reaper got it good that brings us to the
Lazarus device this precious little
beauty not only brings your buddies back
to fighting form in a jiffy it also
negates the health penalty and
incapacitation strike that come with
getting clobbered essentially rendering
all the monsters hard work useless it's
a satisfying and absolutely crucial part
of your duties medic but wait there's
more if you fail to keep your colleagues
alive there's still hope for you to
salvage your tattered dignity by
resurrecting them from the dead pop that
invisibility get close to their corpse
use your Lazarus device to roll away the
stone and low death shall be no more
death thou shalt die unless said death
happens to be in the belly of a big bite
or a megamouth or whatever these things
are called then it's adios partner see
you on the
corruption
alright Lazarus let's review snipe from
afar swoop in with healing bursts use
invisibility for disappearing acts and
stealthy revives don't let anyone die or
stay dead on your watch and by God stay
alive with these strategies and a little
luck you'll make a decent medic yet now
get out there and stay out of combat